North Korea threatens to retaliate
thousands of times against the US for
sponsoring a new set of tougher economic
sanctions at a regional summit in the
Philippines Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson offered to negotiate if the
north stops testing missiles and halts
its nuclear weapons program he spoke
after the UN Security Council
unanimously approved the sanctions North
Korea said in a statement
overnight quote we will pursue our
ambitions to maintain supremacy of
nuclear power forever by launching
intercontinental ballistic missiles we
won't stop for anyone no matter what
they say Julianna Goldman is at the
State Department Julianna good morning
good morning the world's top diplomats
are putting on a full-court press to
make sure these latest sanctions against
North Korea are actually carried out
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is
leaving the door open to negotiating
with North Korea but as far as a time
frame he says we'll know it when we see
it that would be the first and strongest
signal that could send US has just
stopped stop these missile launches at a
Monday press conference Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson said North Korea
must stop their missile launches for an
extended period this is not give me 30
days and we're ready to talk it's not
quite that simple the sanctions were
proved unanimously on Saturday by the
United Nations Security Council and
included the support of Russia and China
the UN estimates it could slash the
North's export revenue by a third after
imposing a ban on exports of coal iron
lead and seafood the package also bars
other nations from importing North
Korean products this is the most
stringent set of sanctions on any
country in a generation UN Ambassador
nikki Haley said the sanctions would
[ __ ] Pyongyang these sanctions will
give the North Korean leadership a taste
of the deprivation they have chosen to
inflict on the North Korean people but
that's only if China stays on board at
the ASEAN conference China took an
uncharacteristically stern posture
telling North Korea's foreign minister
that the regime needed to calm down
accept the sanctions and not retaliate
but Beijing also urged the US and South
Korea to cease military operations and
remove the u.s. THAAD anti-missile
system something neither country accepts
our annual joint military exercises have
been carried out regularly and openly
for nearly 40 years they will continue
China is the big question mark here in
the past they've gone along with
sanctions only to eventually back away
and Charlie the other overriding concern
here is whether or not this is too late
it's going to take some time for the
sanctions to go into effect and
meanwhile North Korea is continuing to
develop its nuclear missile technology
thanks Julianna